bioinformatics for infectious diseases
will consist
of several different elements that work
together to provide
a an experience an immersive experience
for anybody that would like to
learn about the applications of
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so this will include
interactive sessions like we're having
today
it will point you to the right kind of
self-guided study materials that you can
use
in between sessions to cover the topics
that we don't have enough time to cover
as well as some practical assignments so
you'll actually be given
curated data sets you'll be able to
perform analysis
on our big data analysis platform that
will introduce you to
today as well as some coding exercises
so that you can explore
visualize and analyze this data for
biological interpretation
i will not be the only one speaking both
in today's session but also
throughout the program we actually have
a number of
experienced mentors that will be guiding
and assisting you throughout this
program
and that includes dr harpreet kaur who
is a
online logic bioinformatics trainer and
has a phd in bioinformatics
particularly with a specialization in
genomics and oncology
as well as dr mohit mazumder who's also
here in the chat
and he is an expert in chemo informatics
as well as the application or the
relationship between sequence
and structure and i'm sure that he will
mention a little bit about his
background
towards the end of today's session and
so my name is elia brodsky i'm one of
the co-founders
and the ceo of pine biotech but i'm
involved in every aspect
of what our company does and i'm
particularly excited
about this program because i think it's
on everyone's mind
today even people that used to be
interested in oncology and neuroscience
are
now seeing the impact of infectious
diseases
on so many areas that we have been
interested in before
and i think that it's impossible to kind
of overlook the significance of what's
going on not only are we living in the
midst of a pandemic
we always hear in the news how there's
new development
and so because of these developments
it's important to understand
what we can do with the type of data
that is available
in such great quantities on the public
domain
and how we can actually contribute by
analyzing such
data to extract meaningful insights
from some of these data sets so what can
they tell us essentially
so this program called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
is going to focus on the relevant tools
methods data repositories and provide
some examples from curated data sets
where we can take sample data and
analyze it together during these
interactive sessions point you to some
project
examples on the learn omit logic
portal where you can register for free
and we'll be utilizing some of those
examples and tutorials during the
session
so that you can master some key elements
of analysis and visualization tools
and hopefully apply some of these
methods to a project of your
own so the objective of this program and
what we sincerely hope for
everyone that joins this program is that
you will start
and learn about something that is
relevant to a research project that you
would like to develop
now this program is going to last for a
little bit longer than just the previous
program that we
completed not so long ago that program
was exclusively focused
on the covet 19 variants there's some
overlap
between that program and this program
but we hope to
widen the perspective so that we can
look at
sequence variation evolutionary and
phylogenetic analysis like we've done
before
talk about functionality and protein
structure using several different
examples
and then also look at the transcriptomic
data analysis
so that we understand the host responses
and
potentially some of the immunology of
these infectious diseases
so let me for those of you that are
joining with
minimal background virology or
infectious diseases kind of start
from a little bit of a beginning
what are infectious diseases and how are
they different from
non-infectious diseases so infectious
diseases spread
by pathogen by pathogenic microorganisms
and those can include bacteria viruses
parasites and fungi
and you can see some of the examples
here on the left side so flu
hiv malaria and some of these
are very different types of diseases so
they affect different tissues they
affect different types of cells
they have very different mechanisms of
infection
but we call them infectious diseases
because
there are several characteristics about
them that are unique
so for example transmission is an
important factor
the way that they replicate is going to
be an important factor
and this is going to be different from
non-infectious diseases that are not
caused by a pathogen so typically they
are considered to be caused by
environmental factors nutrition
deficiencies lifestyle choices
and genetic inheritance and when we
speak about
this approach of studying infectious
diseases
some of the things that we will be
focusing on are
replication or colonization
cell death so how does the pathogen
induce
the process of deterioration and death
as well as release of toxic and as a
result of that
how we can understand organ and tissue
damage
so these are some of the important
factors and
um surprisingly in the maybe the past
10 or 20 years the researchers have
discovered that
even though we might not consider some
diseases to be
caused by pathogens some of the
conventional diseases that we think
of as non-infectious like cancer and
neurodegenerative diseases
might be associated with some of the
factors and one of the primary reasons
for that
is actually related to the way that our
body responds
to infectious diseases and so to talk a
little bit about the response you can
see here that
for example bacteria
and uh you can see that it is being
uh um the response is
is the ability of the body to kind of uh
uh intercede interceive uh
in intercept right i don't know how to
properly say that
but to intervene um and so when we
speak about infectious diseases we also
have to consider the immune response to
those infectious diseases
where this rapid ability of the pathogen
to
replicate and colonize different tissues
is going to be important for
um okay
sorry one second looks like somebody
signed me out of this
okay so um
okay uh mohit and everyone else if
you're
trying to use my account please stop
that
i think i need it for my presentation
okay ilya so actually the meeting with
uh there's another meeting with
african team about machine learning
so well maybe tell them to use your
account or something else because we do
need this for now
sure okay this is my actually so yeah
okay okay so um
as a result we need to consider the
history
of interventions to help address the
spread of infectious diseases
and over the course of the years
there have been several important
interventions
at the public health level that have
been
very successful at reducing the load
from infectious diseases
and mortality so you can see here the
rate of infection
and the years and some of the important
interventions that have been
developed over the year like the
health departments and the public health
component then you can see the first
continuous municipal use of chlorine in
water in the united states
uh after pandemics especially these
novel interventions have been
applied in a much greater uh way
and then you can see how it helped
intervene with
transmission of important infections the
use of penicillin and the development of
antibiotics as well as
not so long ago if you think about it in
the 1950s the introdu
the introduction of effective
vaccination
and so the types of challenges that we
are facing today
the reason why they are so unexpected is
that we have
a fairly successful history of applying
our understanding of infectious disease
pathogens to prevention and to treatment
of infectious diseases
and so even though we had this high
level of confidence that
we understand the pathogens we
understand that the way they
interact with the host can lead to
disease and we know how to address and
prevent that problem
in the recent pandemic of course there
has been this
novel appreciation of a much more
in-depth characterization of pathogens
that cause
these outbreaks and the ability to
translate our understanding about these
pathogens
to effective interventions and so here
you can see
how the recent pandemic has really
pushed the boundaries of what we know
about
intervention and treatment essentially
making covet 19
one of the leading causes of mortality
for pulmonary diseases that have been
around
since you know for uh decades now
and so what that had led to is a greater
appreciation of the role that
bioinformatics
can play in our monitoring a
characterization
of infectious diseases the way that they
spread
and how we can treat them effectively
and so here you can see a slide from the
new
england journal of medicine where they
described some of the applications of
genomic sequencing
to monitor these outbreaks of infectious
diseases now
one of the first infectious outbreaks
that has
um kind of been you know a breakthrough
moment
for genomic sequencing was the outbreak
of ebola virus in west africa in 2014
2016.
during that time for one of the first
times in history
genomic sequencing was applied in a
very on a large scale to monitor
and characterize the ebola virus that
was causing that outbreak
but you can see some of the other
insights that could be gained from the
analysis of that data including insights
into virulence
protein expression to understand
potential proteins for drug design
proteins and immune response diagnostics
so that you can really understand
the type of a strain or even a specific
variant that is causing some
particular aspect of the clinical
manifestation of disease
insights into growth requirements so
that you can understand drug
susceptibility specific sequences for
strain detection and outbreak
investigation
potentially there could be zoonotic
transmission or a rapid increase in
transmission that could be associated
with the genomic sequence so
really genomics has become a central
focus
for some of the infectious disease
monitoring and
translational research and that's why
using a lot of these applications
combined with the immunology of disease
is really so centered around data
management
data analysis and interpretation and so
when we speak about bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
some of the examples that we're going to
be looking at
is how can we compare different
sequences
from different similar viruses that are
nevertheless divergent
over time and causing different clinical
manifestations
how can we characterize the molecular
level
of infectious disease so that we can
compare the
immune responses and the type of
responses that the human body has these
pathogens
how can we identify some of the
important regions on proteins that are
so critical for the infection itself
and how can we incorporate our
ability to manage and analyze data to
integrate this information together
and gain some reliable and interpretable
biological insights
into disease progression transmission
and treatment of specifically we will
probably focus on
bacterial viral and parasite
pathogens that cause some of the major
diseases out there like covet 19
ebola virus malaria tuberculosis
and others so before we continue i want
to ask if there are any questions
so again if you have any questions
please put them in the chat
i'm going to just give it um one moment
here for anyone to write it out
so the objective of this session today
is to really make sure that the topics
of the upcoming program
are clear that you understand how
you might benefit from joining this
program and
if you have any questions either about
the topics that i've covered so far
or about any of these follow-up topics
please put those in the chat
and i will address them either now or if
i do
have something prepared already i'll
mention that as well
okay so if you have any questions you
can continue posting them in the chat
i will pause in a few more slides and
address them um as well okay and so
arjun
is asking is there a certificate of
completion how valuable could a
certificate of completion from this
course be
in application to a master's program so
it's a great question i think that
anyone
that is trying to learn bioinformatics
one of the important part of
mastering bioinformatics i think is to
apply it to a project of your own
and likely you have a thesis or a
project as a part of your masters
and that's one of the things that you
can really focus on during this program
i don't think that people today when
they hire
uh you know people from uh master
degrees
uh are looking so much at the
certificate that you will get
i think more so they will be looking for
how
uh knowledgeable you are to apply what
you have learned
to tackle a certain problem and so we'll
discuss several case studies
in this program that will allow you to
see
what is the application of
bioinformatics from beginning to the end
of a research project so how can you
find a good data set
how can you plan your analysis how can
you complete that analysis
and what are some of the important
critical questions research questions
that
you can ask about the data set that you
have found
so that the analysis that you present
addresses those questions
in a comprehensive way so you will get a
certificate of completion
but again i think the major outcome for
anyone in a master's level
will be to complete a project and
demonstrate your understanding
of that problem so arjun let me know if
i answered your question
and i'll be happy to expand on that
later on
and then lewis is asking can i
share the last two publications showed
in the slides
yes so we will share all of the links
for these publications
after the session is over if you could
reach out to us by email
so that we have your email address and
we will be happy to share that with you
okay and what does it take to complete
a project so we'll talk a little bit
about the different stages of this
program as i mentioned it's going to
include
training sessions and interactive
sessions like we're having now it will
include some practical introduction to
methods of analysis so that you can take
curated data sets
process them and make sure that you're
getting the right results
but also at the end we will leave some
time for you to
share with us a proposal on a project
that you might find in the public
domain so data sets from ncbi virus
from gis aid from other types of public
domain repositories like maybe malaria
gen
so if you know of a data set you will
have
plenty of time to find and kind of read
the
literature about that data set propose a
project
that you described just kind of based on
your understanding of the logic
this is the data set this is the
question or a comparison that i will ask
maybe you will perform some exploratory
data analysis and at the end you'll have
the opportunity to get some feedback on
the project and so you will be able to
address
any issues that come up so you can maybe
enhance your project make it more
comprehensive make it more interesting
maybe make it more focused on the topics
that are relevant
in that process
okay so uh let me know if i answer that
question
okay great so because we are
living in the time of the pandemic right
we probably all have heard about source
growth ii
the spike protein the genomic variation
of that spike protein
and i think that you know to get started
with
doing something meaningful in this
particular pandemic
the first thing that we need to
understand is how
relevant the different data that is
available
to a an impactful question right and so
i think that i would divide this
training into two parts
the first part which you might as well
do on your own
or you can do it together with our group
here
is to learn about some of the basics the
basics
related to where did this virus come
from how do we use bioinformatics to
analyze data and test some of the
hypotheses that were proposed
what are some of the basic outcomes of
the analysis that we can use
to answer some of the questions and so
i'm going to go through a few examples
and this is the first one
and i'm using it as the first one
because this kind of an
introductory project is something that
you can try out
after you have completed your
registration on this portal
so again i know that we already did this
in the beginning of today's session
but if you have already logged in
let's go back to learn onyxlogic.com
and if you haven't please let register
on this portal so
that you can follow along and see some
of the examples that we will be showing
here in the next few slides
okay so this is the link you will see
that
once you have logged in you will have a
profile
and you will have some personal
suggestions based on your progress
so as you start completing some of these
tutorials
and mastering some of these skills it
will start changing
as you go through the course work and so
right here you see that we have the
colgate 19
origin and pathogenesis of source cove
2. so i'm going to share that link with
you as well
again if you haven't registered
registration here is free so just please
go ahead
and get started and one of the first
things
and this i think will provide you with a
good understanding of how this program
will work
you will see setting the background
right setting
the stage for what kind of questions
should we be asking and how to translate
those
theoretical questions to practical data
analysis process
so you'll see here some introduction
about the coronaviruses
and what do they do what is the
important part of it
with transmission and then you will also
see what are some of the
important factors that you can learn
about here and
here you will see some of the objectives
some of the specific objectives that
will be covered
in this course in this project and so
similar to this project
in the course of this whole program we
will actually go
through quite a number of examples like
this
so this one is on source code two
another one that we will go through is
malaria
where databases like malaria gen
and plasmodb offer us access to
a comprehensive collection of data from
different regions where malaria is
endemic
to identify some important factors on
drug resistance
on transmission as well as vaccine
efficacy
in application to different types of
data about different proteins different
populations
different years and so we'll be
exploring that data together as well as
a part of this program
as i mentioned one of the first examples
where
pandemics or epidemics have been
characterized at the genomic level
almost in real time is the ebola virus
and so one of the projects that we will
be focused on
is that tracking of ebola virus
evolution across that 2014-2016
epidemic in west africa and so as a
result of these
projects that we will dive into to
understand their background
to understand the specific questions
that could be asked about them
and understand some of the tools and
methodologies you will be able to
appreciate the role of omix data
in infectious disease research and the
application of bioinformatics to be able
to ask specific questions about these
data sets and so that will give you an
insight into viral genomics and
evolution immune response biomarkers
and the relationship between microbiome
and infection
now at the core of all of these types of
omics data
we will primarily focus on next
generation sequencing and one of the
aspects of next generation sequencing is
that the technology itself
has evolved rapidly over the past
couple of decades essentially leading us
to where we are today where
there's just millions and millions of
sequences
and hundreds of thousands of data sets
that are available for anyone to explore
and access in the public domain that
means that
as someone that comes without the lab
capabilities of generating your own data
you can have access to data sets
produced
at top labs around the world in the best
academic centers where people that have
been trained for years
are sharing data that they generate and
all of us can just
take that data and analyze it and what
that means is that it eliminates the
concerns about the quality of data
it eliminates the concerns about the
quantity of data so both quantity is
there
and quality is there and so i think that
makes this
an exciting opportunity and i think that
infectious diseases
is one of those areas where data is even
more prevalent and available
than than some of the other conditions
that you might be interested in
but to understand this data we have to
appreciate
the heterogeneity of this data as well
so essentially
as i mentioned the sequencing
technologies have evolved over the
years tremendously and now we have
short read sequences long read sequences
some of the technologies are
much easier to generate quality data
some of them have
some of these other issues and so we
will review the different types of
next-generation sequencing
data and data types before we jump into
that and so before i go into that
process of next generation sequencing
again i want to ask if you have any
questions
about what we have covered so far so
what we covered so far is
the overview of the omixlearn
omixlogiclearn
platform or portal where you will have
access to data sets
and tutorials that you can learn from
asynchronously
number two we started talking about
infectious diseases and how
research in infectious diseases can be
conducted
as a part of this program where you will
be able to
apply the tools that you learn to data
sets that you find
on your own in the public domain
number three you will understand the
different types of data that
are available for the questions that you
might be asking
so you really have the freedom to choose
the type of a project or the type of an
application or a question that you might
have about these data sets
so again if you have a question please
put that in the chat box
and i'll be if i see the questions now
i'll be answering them now
if not then we will wait until the next
pause that we will have
to answer any questions that you might
have
okay so dr amitabh is asking
is the best pathway to complete the
introduction to bioinfo course before
enrolling
for this one um yes
if you are completely new to
bioinformatics uh what i would recommend
uh and let me actually um show you a
couple of things where you can get
started depending on kind of
where you see yourself uh going with
this process
there's a course on introduction to
bioinformatics that explains the
different applications of bioinformatics
about medicine to agriculture
etc there's also a course called
bytes and molecules so bites and
molecules
is a course for somebody who's you know
just beginning to kind of learn about
some of these topics
and you will see that here you will have
an introduction to
the human genome project you will see
the application of citizen science
how do these two kind of paradigms
converge together
to create a need for bioinformatics or
for
training in data science and then you
will see some of the basics what is the
genome what are nucleotides what are
amino acids how do we go from sequence
to function
right so some of those basic things are
going to be explained in this course as
well
so either one introduction to
bioinformatics is kind of probably the
next step
and then bites and molecules is the kind
of first level where
you would begin as a newbie to this
topic
does that answer your question dr
amitabh
all right excellent so let's go on so
next generation sequence
to appreciate the opportunities provided
by
next generation sequencing we really
need to understand how next generation
sequencing works
and the way it works is that there's a
machine
that essentially takes the raw
biological material or rna
and dna and converts it into digital
data and this data consists of short
sequences
or reads as we call them that now
represent
a digital snapshot of what happens
at the subcellular level now when we
speak about infectious diseases that
means that we have
millions and millions of reeds about
that pathogen the virus the bacteria or
the parasite
and potentially how does it actually
look in a real biological sample
and it looks like this right so this is
the result of mapping those short reads
onto the reference genome this is by the
way
one of the first examples of mapping the
sequencing data from the wuhan outbreak
onto the reference genome
of the previously known sars one virus
where you can see how many many short
reads
provide us with an understanding of what
is the consensus sequence
that we're ultimately going to be
looking at and so to be able to
analyze this data we can perform what's
called
sequence alignment and the sequence
alignment could be applied
in two different ways one of them is
alignment to
a reference when we have the raw reads
and we want to understand
the consensus or the variation from the
reference
or if we have a number of these
consensus sequences
how do they relate to each other or
multiple sequence alignment
where we can now explore the
relationship between them
based on variation that we see in the
sequences themselves
and so to seeing the application of
how these methods could be used let's go
on to the server
that omix yeah server that t-bioinfo
where we will see how we can analyze
this data
and this is going to be for anyone even
if you don't have any background
in bioinformatics at all so i'm going to
go to
server.tbio.info if you
register on the learn omixlogic
portal you can use the same password
that you used there
maybe some of you already have a
password so just log in
and we'll take a look at one of the
sections to kind of see
what the process of analysis consists of
so once you're here we will see
how this portal has several different
topics that you could apply
analysis to and that includes analysis
of next generation sequencing data
mass spectroscopy structural biology as
well as methods for data integration and
modeling and so what we want to do
is see how analysis of these sequences
can help reveal relationship between
these sequences
in application to a question that we
might have
about the source growth ii virus so i'm
going to go
under phylogenetic tree and i'll find
here several different demo examples
and one of those examples is going to be
this one source code to
origin right so it says i have to click
on the drop down
and then i have to click on demo source
code to origin
so as a as a demo as an example we don't
have to upload the data
the data is already here what we need to
do is we need to click on several
of these buttons to see how this data
could be analyzed so what is the
process what is the flow or the logic
behind such analysis
so we have two options as we mentioned
we can upload fast queue or fasta data
in this case you can see the input files
and those are
bad coronavirus bad source code 2
human source code 2 as well as some
pangolin data sets on source code 2.
right so the question here and this is
the question
asked in the tutorial that i shared
earlier is what is the relationship
between different sequences how could
they be
organized into what's called the
phylogenetic tree
so that we can analyze their
evolutionary
closeness how closely related they are
and when could they have diverged into
these separate directions
of adaptation and that could help answer
the question
what is this virus in humans and how
could it be related to some of these
proposed intermediate hosts
like bats or penguins
so i'll click on the start then i'm
going to use multiple sequence alignment
to compare these
i will convert them to amino acid
sequences so i can understand the
impact of those mutations on the protein
sequences
and then i will use all phylogenetic
methods that are listed right here
to perform this phylogenetic analysis
now once i have many different
phylogenetic trees based on different
models mathematical models that kind of
represent
the molecular clock or the molecular
evolution that i observe at the
sequence level i can also analyze the
phylogenetic tree structures
to identify the best one that is
kind of convergent between these
different trees that i've
gotten as a result of many different
methods of analysis
so after i'm done with this pipeline i
will have here
several different outputs and i'm going
to take one of these
to see whether i can understand
something about
the relationship of these virus viral
genomes
so when i open this plot i'm going to
see here
different names and these names
represent
different fasta files that i have
uploaded
and so to appreciate the results i have
to annotate them
so essentially i have to look at how are
these
represented as a phylogenetic tree right
so each
branch here represents a
split from the origin and the nodes
represent a common potential ancestor
and so we can use this analysis to
understand how
evolutionary time or adaptation the
process of evolution that we observe at
the genomic level
has gotten us the present day species
that we have collected with samples that
we have collected
so if we apply this technique to ebola
virus
we can ask the question about how the
different regions
like gabon liberia and great britain
relate to each other based on genomic
sequences
if we look at the source code 2 we can
also identify as i mentioned the
relationship between
the human source code 2 the back corona
virus
rad g13 or the bad source like
coronavirus
as well as the pangolin and other types
of stars human viruses
so we can see the relationship overall
we can also find specific amino acid
mutations in critical regions for
example this
spike glycoprotein mutation d
to g that was prevalent and became one
of the dominant mutations
potentially linked to increased
transmission rate
in the sars corona virus so that is
the second part of what we will do in
this program and we'll talk about
how do we find what are called mutations
or snips and so these snips or mutations
or variants
are important to be able to analyze
categorize and characterize in terms of
their
impact on the phenotype and so
once we perform alignment and we can
perform alignment
on nucleotide and amino acid level
what we're interested in are different
types of mutations
missense mutations nonsense mutations
and frame shift mutations and we want to
find
particularly those positions that could
indicate
a change in the protein structure so
it could be done using multiple sequence
alignment
or it could be used by looking at all of
the reeds that we have that represent
potentially many different viruses
present in a sample and identify in
identifying
variants of importance and that is
called variant
calling and so by variant calling we can
identify
those snips that have a potential impact
and then we can use
different methods of characterization of
protein
function to understand how relevant they
might be
for a specific question of the impact of
that mutation on
a structural component that we have
identified as important to what we're
studying and so here you can see
several different ways ways that we can
look at that
and several different ways that we can
interpret this kind of information
so what we'll do in the program itself
is we'll actually
take these models of proteins
that are on the host side like for
example here you can see
the host side h2 protein which is in
blue
but in reality this protein is actually
part of the complex
and this complex sits within the bo81
sodium-dependent neutral amino acid
transporter
and then we'll also find the spike
protein which also
what we have from crystallography
studies
is just a component of that protein but
we'll look at how they
relate to each other by using ucsf
chimera and kind of mapping those 3d
structures onto each other
helping us understand how this virus
actually
binds to the host cell you can see the
membrane right here
and then try to make the interpretation
of a
mutation of a change in the structure
based on the impact that that would have
on protein
protein interaction just like we're
seeing here
so again this will give us some insight
into how
spike protein of sars cove 2
which is a critical protein for both the
transmission
but also the vaccine prevention of that
transmission and prevention of
disease play a critical role the
mutations right those variants play a
critical role in all of those aspects
as we anticipate this pandemic to
continue and spread
and so in this program the
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
we will cover sequence variation
evolutionary relationships and how those
are measured
functional inference for sequence to
structure
and function as well as host response
how can we analyze
the response of the host transcriptomic
data rna-seq data
to find patterns that can explain
some of the reactions that we see
between mild
maybe severe disease maybe symptomatic
disease
right maybe we can look into the
immunology of different immune cells
etc